quello che vorrei raccontarvi oggi è
appunto la storia di un di un progetto
italiano di un bel progetto italiano che
che si è sviluppato e si continua a
sviluppare seguendo un approccio
seguendo un modello che in qualche modo
sintetizzato da una parola una parola
che spesso viene vista come una parola
l'amata come una parola che viene
utilizzata per fare green washing per
fare make up del di processi e di
aziende che si vogliono fingere verdi o
attenti all'ambiente ma in realtà non lo
sono in realtà cosa parola dentro un
significato molto importante e già
prefigura in sé tutto un modello di
sviluppo e quindi se ritorniamo un po a
quello che è
l'importanza e il significato della
parola parola che un sostantivo
femminile che deriva dal latino parabola
e che poi da parabola diventa parola
come già nella vulgata
la parola di gesù è la parola di dio per
eccellenza e quindi è la parola che si
porta con sé un significato importante e
quindi su questo mi piace citare un film
che mi è piaciuto molto di un regista
italiano che è nanni moretti e che in
palombella rossa nel 1989 fa dire al
protagonista michele apicella che parla
con una giornalista che usa a parola
sproposito per fare notizia per fare
scoop le urla in faccia
bisogna scegliere bene le parole perché
le parole sono importanti e quindi la
scelta della parola è importante perché
deve raccontare in modo concreto e
veritiero quello che che facciamo e
questa parola non è una parola
misteriosa non è una parola nuova e la
parola sostenibilità parola
sostenibilità che appunto nasce da
da molti anni a una definizione che
visiterò a breve e sostanzialmente nasce
da tutto quel lavoro quella
consapevolezza che alla fine degli anni
sessanta con i movimenti ambientalisti
inizia ad emergere con il rapporto del
club of rome del 1972 che è un ottimo
thank inizio a capire le problematiche
della finitezza delle risorse del
pianeta del pianeta e la problematica di
un modello di utilizzo delle risorse che
è sempre più dissipativo e non
conservativo con una tendenza che è
appunto a un aumento di questo approccio
invece che è una diminuzione e quindi
quelle conferenze che ci sono state poi
dell'onu sul clima e con il rapporto
della commissione bronzola nel
1982 si arriva a questa definizione di
sostenibilità che sostenibilità una
condizione di uno sviluppo che sei in
grado di assicurare il soddisfacimento
dei bisogni delle generazioni presenti
senza compromettere la possibilità delle
generazioni future di realizzare i
propri su questo scienziati economisti
filosofi si sono arrovellati hanno
prodotto teorie e modelli definendo
anche i limiti di un concetto
di questo tipo ma sostanzialmente il
invitano a ricordarsi che nel pensare
allo sviluppo nel pensare al futuro
dobbiamo ricordarci anche di quello che
che ci sarà dopo è
quello che è un importante centro di
ricerca sulla resilienza del pianeta che
è il stockholm resilience center
teorizza è che nel nostro pianeta ci
sono appunto dei confini naturali
chiamano i confini planetari al di sotto
del quale l'umanità si dovrebbe
mantenere per non rischiare di avere dei
problemi e dei disastri ambientali tali
per cui sarà difficile ritornare
indietro e all'interno di questi confini
c'è un area dove anche il benessere
sociale e il benessere delle persone
deve mantenersi entro un ambito di
accessibilità alle risorse per garantire
che ci sia un equilibrio del pianeta e
se pensiamo che ancora adesso il 13 per
cento della popolazione mondiale e
denutrita il 19 per cento non ha accesso
all'elettricità il 21 per cento vive in
condizioni di povertà
estrema capiamo che siamo ancora molto
ben lontani da questi obiettivi
a novembre a parigi ci sarà la
conferenza sul clima dell'onu in molti
stanno lavorando per far sì che in
questo contesto si riesca finalmente a
prendere delle decisioni che possano
essere vincolanti per i paesi per
cominciare a ripensare lo sviluppo uno
sviluppo che non sia soltanto
concentrato sull'aumento del pil ma che
si renda conto che i costi ambientali
così sociali diventano un fattore
limitante per lo sviluppo del nostro
pianeta
emblematico leggere il rapporto del
l'ultimo g20 dove ancora nonostante
tutto il termine pil il pil inteso
proprio come unico elemento uni come
unico parametro di crescita economica
venga ancora trattato come in fondo il
cambiamento climatico le problematiche
ambientali vengano visti quasi come un
un ostacolo allo sviluppo delle imprese
quindi quello che vorrei raccontarvi
oggi usando una parola che per noi ha un
significato importante che cerchiamo di
usare come guida del nostro sviluppo
vorrei raccontarvi la storia di una
realtà e di un di uno sviluppo che ha
visto che comunque
lavorando sull'ambiente lavorando con
l'agricoltura integrando chimica
agricoltura ambiente si è riusciti
comunque a fare impresa questa storia
comincia a 25 anni fa dall'idea di un
imprenditore che
lavorando e avendo interessi su più
ambiti dall'ambiente ambito
agroalimentare l'ambiente chimico ha
capito che sviluppando nuove tecnologie
si potevano ottenere dei prodotti
interessanti
questo progetto poi è andato avanti e
continua ancora adesso e a la serie a
novara grazie
alla volontà e alla creatività la
capacità innovativa di una ricercatrice
un gruppo di ricercatori che con lei ha
lavorato in questi anni quello che si
capì però già allora era che lo sviluppo
di queste di queste realtà di questo
modello di sviluppo poteva e può aver
senso soltanto se diventa un progetto
non solo di una singola impresa ma
diventa il progetto di un territorio
diventa un progetto dove le istituzioni
dove il mondo ambientalista
dove chi fa e disegna alle politiche di
sviluppo territoriali lavora a fianco
delle imprese per far sì che poi il
divario tra impresa ambiente istituzioni
non diventi incolmabile
molte cose sono state fatte in questi
anni e quello che vi voglio far vedere
quello che ha portato questa questa
innovazione che parte da un concetto di
sviluppo che oggi si chiama bio economia
economia circolare c'è un'economia che
utilizza le risorse del territorio
quelle che quelle che abbiamo qui a
quello che è quello che è più
vantaggioso
per l'ambiente e per le caratteristiche
del paese è sviluppare che sono appunto
le risorse rinnovabili e cerca di
lavorare sulle risorse rinnovabili con
un concetto di economia circolare dove
ogni elemento di questo sviluppo e di
questo e dei processi che lo
caratterizzano non presenta o comunque
minimizza tutti quelli che possono
essere degli scarti e fa sì che ogni
elemento ogni stream di questa filiera
diventi valore aggiunto per filiere
contigue
quindi vi faccio vedere questa foto che
appunto di nuovo ha veramente poco
sembra un impianto un bel impianto
industriale un impianto luogo con un
cielo terso
all'orizzonte
è però vi faccio vedere poi che cosa c'è
quali sono gli altri pezzi di questa
storia che sono dei campi i campi di
cardo ci sono degli agricoltori con
delle trebbiatrici che che raccolgono
questi cardi e ci sono anche delle
pecore
ci sono delle pecore perché sono un
pezzo di questa storia perché questo
modello di sviluppo si basa sulla aver
identificato e aver studiato con gli
agricoltori del territorio quindi i
ricercatori del territorio quelle che
erano le caratteristiche la biodiversità
che caratterizzava in particolare un
sito in sardegna dove grazie alla così
alla storia della chimica italiana più
tradizionale si trovava con delle delle
grandi problematiche ambientali e
occupazionali e quindi lavorando insieme
se riusciti a sviluppare
una cultura
capendo con gli agricoltori quali
potevano essere i terreni e i territori
dove andare a coltivare a riportare
reddito
al territorio utilizzando la cultura per
cui una parte viene utilizzata per
produrre nuovi prodotti nuovi geni che
grazie a un innovazione tecnologica che
si è sviluppata negli anni e da una
parte di questi di questa cultura si
riescono a ottenere le proteine per per
nutrire le pecore sarde che sono tante e
la sardegna oggi importa la totalità del
proprio mangime dal
dall'estero dal continente come dicono
loro e quindi questo questo progetto
vede filiere diverse che crescono su un
grande progetto iniziale questo è il
concetto di bioraffineria in cui
l'italia è all'avanguardia a livello
europeo ma anche a livello
internazionale
e che dal punto di vista della
competitività del settore chimico su
questo settore può portare veramente dei
dei vantaggi in termini occupazionali in
termini di ricerca e in termini di
innovazione il questo progetto però come
come disse chi chi l'ha fondo può
effettivamente diventare un progetto
radicato puoi diventare un progetto che
che genera ulteriori opportunità
soltanto se insieme le istituzioni
le imprese il mondo ambientalista
lavorano insieme per creare le
condizioni di sviluppo
di questo di questo settore e quindi
ritornando a da quello che era il
concetto iniziale
del ritornare a a pensare che per fare
modelli per sviluppare modelli di
sviluppo diversi bisogna anche
cominciare a pensare in modo diverso
provare a pensare in modo diverso e
quindi per far questo è importante
credere
in
pensieri e in in concetti che sono
positivi e su questo mi mi collego a una
frase di un grande uomo della storia
dell'umanità che appunto gandhi e
sull'importanza della
mantenere pensieri positivi perché i
tuoi pensieri diventano parole
mantieni le tue parole positive perché
le tue parole diventano i tuoi
comportamenti
mantiene i tuoi comportamenti positivi
perché i tuoi comportamenti diventano le
tue abitudini mantiene le tue abitudini
positive perché le tue abitudini
diventano i tuoi valori mantiene i tuoi
valori positivi perché i tuoi valori
diventano il tuo destino e quindi
secondo noi la sfida di oggi sta
nell'essere a servizio della qualità di
vita di tutti e lo si può fare non solo
se siete e volontario dei filantropi ma
anche se si fa impresa innovazione in
questo modo generare una vera e propria
rivoluzione un cambiamento culturale che
riguarda tutti noi è che se si vuole si
può